you're late report right so per your
orders and since is released from Arkham
six months ago I've been keeping
occasional tabs on Jervis Tetch aka the
Mad Hatter two weeks ago I brought along
my squad spoiler era wet and orphan bats
touch for a Mad Hatter he's kind of well
hapless no it's it's a condition of his
parole hmm
good thing he's not called the med pan
sir he's heading for his night job right
on schedule although the water yeah hot
water he's drinking a lot of it and
awfully fast
[Music]
so do we bust him for littering hmm
clay backwash Oh gross so you're
thinking yeah it's possible anyway we
need to find a way to check
wait where's orphan did you know touch
was really clean face or just not care
they're not buddies which means tech
she's probably controlling him doesn't
matter
we know where touch is so forget
Clayface let's go get Hatter
we don't know where tech is but Clayface
clearly does and I tossed a liquid
tracker on him nice
[Music]
everyone out of the building now I'm not
touching whoever he was running with
were later get out now
[Music]
you do Hagan the building's going to
explode
[Music]
lazy he he didn't make it I think he'll
be fine
and really angry at Jervis Tetch
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new young justice and WTF
moments to talk about obviously brand
new bad family we finally saw a Tim
Drake comeback in a really big way we
saw him in his new costume in the first
episode but there's so many new
characters for them to introduce it just
took a while for them to get to a Batman
family episode but there's so much more
than this there's the origin of Vandal
Savage the origin of the light in his
relationship with Darkseid probably one
of the best episodes so far then a whole
bunch of new characters that they
introduced with all the Justice League's
children so we'll do a new round of that
DC streaming service giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
episodes on the video so starting with
the new Batman family just to explain
who these new characters are then I'll
work through top 10 WTF moments you'll
start with number 10 new Batman family
is obviously Batman
Nightwing Oracle Barbara Gordon they
still not explained whether or not we've
already missed Killing Joke and that's
how she wound up in the wheelchair I
think that it is because they're
relatively comic-book accurate when it
comes to that really crazy stuff but
we'll probably hear about that in a
flashback in a future episode but then
obviously Tim Drake that has a new
costume Stephanie Brown spoiler era wet
and orphan orphan is Cassandra Cain if
you guys didn't know that so this is the
daughter of Lady Shiva
I'm sure they'll explain that in some
future episode but don't forget we also
have Damian Wayne that we just learned
about in last week's batch of episodes
in obviously Red Hood who will
eventually probably become a member of
the Batman family in a future season
this season seems like it's more about
the revelation that he's still alive and
then him going up against the Batman
family then maybe them slowly turning
him him going off on his own and then
you know maybe he'd a long time down the
road he eventually works with them but
when it comes to Batman family stuff Red
Hood is kind of like a contract player
like he's never gonna be like the other
Batman family members even though he
cares about him his personality just
won't allow him to get close to people
like that anymore so even if he helps
them out he's still not gonna pal around
or bunk up with them all the time
but number nine WTF the origin of Vandal
Savage is the origin of metahumans on
planet earth the origin of the human
race and the origin of the light the
episode was a really good job of putting
everything that he does into context
like he is the father of the world so to
speak like when they call him Genghis
Khan during the episode think about all
the children the Genghis Khan had that
means that most of the people on planet
earth shares some genetic material with
Vandal Savage number eight the origin of
Vandal Savage fight with Darkseid
beginning thousands of years ago when he
was known as Genghis Khan this is
actually pretty cool like Darkseid came
to clunker planet Earth but Vandal
Savage
didn't quite fight him off but impressed
him and formed a truce that gets into
more of why they're using metahumans to
conquer the galaxy so they're spreading
them all over but the idea is is that
once they do conquer the galaxy they'll
have a final battle between Vandal
Savage and whoever's left on planet
Earth and whoever's left on apocalypse
they jump forward in time number seven
one of vandal savage's sons was the
original dr. fate now they call him
Naboo but that's just what they're
calling him when he was inhabited by
Naboo spirit wearing the helmet of fate
he was that current version of dr. fate
the being that is known as Naboo is one
of the oldest living beings in the
universe he's one of the Lords of order
their race came into existence in the
dawn of creation so he went to Planet
Earth to help guide the human race so he
would inhabit someone and that person
would become that dr. fate the Lords of
chaos is where you get to Clarion he's
sort of the antithesis of Naboo so
that's why it's so important that he
stay on planet earth six vandal savage's
battle with Starro in the past as well
as in the present so they used this to
tell the story of the origin of the
light I really felt like this is one of
their strongest episodes the way they
used the war world the animation was
great as well as the story in how they
used it to bookend the story of the
origin of everything it was unclear
whether or not he was actually killing
the Storrow or just one of stauros
children like Starro is a being that can
create many smaller versions of itself
to control large groups of people that's
how it was controlling this space fleet
and trying to use it to take over the
planet so when he's packing up the
pieces and throwing it in those
containment cells inside war world
it's unclear whether or not that's the
biggest version of Starro or if there's
another one out there somewhere that's
controlling this larger one that it
itself was controlling the smaller ones
that was controlling the fleet so should
be noted if you look in the background
you actually see Mangal in one of those
cells which explains how Vandal Savage
got Warworld
sounds like Mangal did not turn it over
willingly but look at all the cells in
the background here - meaning these are
all probably super powerful beings that
did not see eye to eye with Vandal
Savage that he's keeping in lockdown
number five WTF was in killing his
oldest daughter Olympia you really did
start to care about her by the end of
the episode she's pretty sympathetic did
you read the story about the bear that
was my favorite story as he slowly
crushes the life out of her but number
four was all the Mad Hatter mind-control
stuff with Simon Staggs device so the
whole idea is is that Simon Stagg was a
part of the light that got paranoid so
he's using the mind control serum to
form his own little small squad to
protect himself from the other members
of the light but obviously the whole
episode and all this mind-control stuff
was meant to show you that the villains
aren't necessarily always the bad people
there's always someone worse that may be
pulling their strings so this batch of
episodes really did try to make the
villains and especially the light in
general more sympathetic especially when
you get to all the ocean master stuff in
the other episode so three other brief
new Young Justice scene versus Lobo it's
really cool to see Lobo in an episode
they kill halo again very gruesomely
again so I'm just assuming that every
batch of episodes we're gonna see her
die in some horrific way number two was
meeting all the new kids of the Justice
League so we meet Barry and irises twins
the tornado twins this is exactly how it
is from the comics now obviously I do a
lot of flash live-action episodes and
they're doing Nora not the tornado twins
I've already done some Theory videos
about how they might get to tornado
twins by the end of season 5 but Young
Justice is just doing the comic book
version no special twists or anything
like that love the iris moment with Bart
Allen please Bart don't call him dad
even though technically dawn Allen the
boy is Bart Allen's father but you also
meet Superman and Lois Lane's son Jon
Kent and what a coincidence he's about
the same age as baby
Damian Wayne Batman's son so just think
about this in a future season if we get
a big time jump maybe there'll be like
five or six years old during season four
and they can actually do some cool stuff
but probably the number one WTF was
ocean master who had recently escaped
from prison trying to use the Trident of
Poseidon in a nuclear option to destroy
the Justice League's children in all
their wives with a single blow but the
light steps in and stops him by chopping
his head off before he can do that
because they don't want mutually assured
destruction so it's a really cool way of
showing how cold and calculating the
light is not that they care about the
Justice League's children that's not why
they save them they did that because
they know that the Justice League would
retaliate and kill all of them so is
just a cool way of reminding you that
they're cold-hearted bastards but they
know what they can and can't get away
with so the other really big moment at
the end of the episode was revealing
that granny goodness is behind the VR
goggles that'll probably have something
to do with the anti-life equation in
taking over everyone's minds before the
end of the season we don't know exactly
how many of these arcs that they're
setting up they'll culminate in this
first block of 13 episodes but they're
26 episodes total so some stuff will
spill into the second half of the season
well let me know in the comments what
was your guy's favorite moment from the
episodes really sodding justice season 3
has been awesome so far so if you have
any special requests for Young Justice
videos just leave them in the comments
below the Dragon Ball super bro Lee
movie just dropped in theaters people
have been asking for a spoiler review so
I might do that sometime soon there'll
be new Marvel new Game of Thrones
posting in the next couple of days
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all the
videos that I post no worries
but click here to learn about the really
huge MCU character that just bought the
Avengers tower in the spider-man far
from home trailer and click here to
re-watch both those really big
spider-man far from home trailers thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]